the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
due to technical difficulties only a
portion of lecture 1 is available for
viewing welcome to teaching
college-level science and engineering
title contains the word teaching which
may spark some questions in your mind
for example is teaching just an art or
is it something that's just something
you're born with in which case there's a
either you have it or you don't have it
well obviously I don't believe that or I
wouldn't be teaching in a course on it
what would be the point
or is it purely a science where there's
a set of equations and procedures to
learn and then all of a sudden you'll be
an excellent teacher
well actually it's neither and it's both
it's it's things that we're all born
with on the one hand and there are also
procedures and techniques and ways of
thinking that will improve how you teach
and that we can all learn so it's a
happy mix my favorite mix on art and a
science so for example another example
that's an art and a science is book
design so compared to for example just
pure art painting say modern painting
very unconstrained versus say biology
procedures in the laboratory you know
very very closely specified it's
somewhere in between there's an art but
there's of all the arts of color space
but they all have to be used together to
achieve a particular purpose so again
and there there's some beautifully
designed books and some not so
beautifully designed books and there are
principles behind that that we can use
to design good books so similarly there
are principles we can use to design good
teaching so this is the whole point of
this semester
is to design good teaching and how you
do that and rather than me give you a
big long theory about it because
actually there isn't really theory so
much in equivalent to say Einstein's
theory of relativity but there's
principles to learn the best way to
learn those principles is with an
example so what we're going to do today
is I'm going to do an example of
teaching with you we're gonna do it sort
of maybe a slightly sped up version of
what we would normally do say if we were
actually using this example in a class
then we're gonna analyze why it was done
that way and from that analysis general
principles of teaching will come out
that will be addressed throughout the
semester and they'll be addressed in the
context of particular tasks like for
example how to make slides that are
useful for teaching how to use a
blackboard how to teach equations how to
design a whole course how to make
problems so all of those tasks will be
the week-by-week subjects and in each
tasks all the principles that we're
going to talk about now well actually
will show up in those tasks and you'll
see the principles illustrated
repeatedly okay so the the problem one
of my favorites so these are two cones
one is it has twice the dimensions of
the other cone so let me show you how I
made the cones
so I printed out a circle and just cut
out 1/4 of the circle and then I taped
this edge to that edge or in
mathematician speak I identified the
edges which now I know means I tape the
edges together and then you get a cone
like that
so this cone and the other cone were cut
out of the same sheet of paper except
this one has twice the linear dimensions
in its circle I think this this circle
was 7 centimeters in radius and this is
3 and 1/2 centimeters in radius so other
than that they're the same the question
is which one has the higher terminal
velocity or are they about comparable so
in particular the question is this so
I'm going to drop them and the question
is what's their ratio of their terminal
velocities
so the ratio of the big cones terminal
velocity to the small cones terminal
velocity is equal to what and you get
choices along this axis so here's a so
those are the five regions to choose
from so you have five choices for the
ratio basically roughly 1/4 this is some
range here because nothing's exact and
we're certainly not going to do an exact
experiment roughly one half roughly one
roughly two or roughly four so does
everyone understand the question is
you're going to get to try it yourself
question about the question
sure hi so yeah should I restate the
question no problem all right so I'm
gonna drop them just like this no tricks
I'm not gonna you know flip this one
around or anything and the question is
what's the ratio of their terminal speed
so they write away as soon as you let go
of them they come to a steady speed
which is their terminal velocity and the
question is how did the terminal speeds
of the big one and the small one differ
okay so in particular the question is
what's the ratio and there's five
choices for them okay does that help oh
so this guy is he was cut out of a
circle who was seven centimeters in
radius and this guy was cut out of a
circle who was three and a half
centimeters in radius and then I was
also very careful to use you know to do
this right yeah I used half the width of
tape on the small guy as I did on the
big guy just to get it really very
perfectly scale-invariant okay any
questions about the question
okay so think to yourself for about only
30 seconds or so just to induct yourself
into the problem and then we'll take a
vote okay and then you'll have a chance
to discuss it with each other
okay let's just take a vote and so I
recognize I haven't given you at all
enough time to come up with an exact
answer or calculate everything and
that's by design
all right so let's just get a straw poll
and then you'll have a chance to argue
with your neighbor about it so who votes
for 1/4 which is that the zone we'll see
one two three four five six votes for
one-half
votes for C about twenty two votes for D
no takers no takers for D okay how about
E okay so now find a neighbor or to one
or two neighbors introduce yourself to
your neighbor and also by the way unless
you're taking notes on your laptop and
really insist on doing that if you could
close your laptop that would be very
helpful for the purposes of discussion
in this whole course all right so find a
neighbor or to introduce yourself you'll
be getting a chance to meet graduate
students from across the Institute it's
a great opportunity and try to convince
them of your answer especially if you
have a different answer or if you should
happen to share an answer well see if
you can figure out why you're sure of it
or if you're not sure of it see if you
can settle it settle back
okay so discussion time and if you have
any questions that come up as you're
discussing raise your hand and I'll come
and wander over
okay so meanwhile I also handed out
feedback sheets for the end of the
session which I'll ask you to just spend
a minute on at the end but you'll notice
one of the questions is what's the most
confusing thing so if anything really
confusing comes up during the whole
session you can just put it right then
you don't have to wait till the end or
if there's something you really liked or
hated that's question to you can put
that whenever it happens to come up but
vote number two and then we'll take some
reasons so 1/4
one two three okay for one half the
halves don't have it oh there's one
oh there's two okay great three four
five six and equal okay that's about
let's call it 32 and four okay
so thanks for the votes let's take
reasons for any of them I'll take
reasons for any of them I'll put them up
here you don't even have to agree with
the reasons just something you guys
discussed and thought maybe was
plausible yes so you're say you're not
sure how to phrase this let me just take
other comments I don't want I'll come to
that afterwards other comments for any
of the reasons so again it doesn't have
to be things you necessarily believe but
things that are plausible and that's
actually more instructive than what you
think is for sure right because you're
now you're trying to figure out what
might be true and you're expanding the
wazers thinking yeah
okay see so mass to area ratio is the
same okay can people think of plausible
reasons against that argument yes right
mm-hmm
right so let's call this Nazi so suppose
the formula actually depended on the
square root of a or square of a or
something like that but you know me it's
say one chance out of three that it has
a to the first power here I could have a
to the one-half or a to the two so could
be a to the K M over a to the K for K
not equal to one
okay others for or against see intuitive
reasons or for any of the others
okay so hopefully that's oh yes okay so
let's see F drag horse on the area and
weight or filter area so that's an
argument for which choice for C okay how
do you know that the drag scales of the
area maybe it scales with square root of
area hmm any arguments pro or con
okay yeah
okay so there's a so so for this let's
say there's a thought experiment of
subdividing so I'll just note that as
subdividing thought experiment yeah so
it may depend on the division I mean on
the geometry I so I'll put that up here
as geometry what else might it depend on
for example is air resistance say always
for worse malaria
whoo yep
okay so it might depend on the material
I've and and it certainly does which is
actually one reason I was very careful
to construct them out of the same piece
of paper all right so let me put this as
the material so they the surface
roughness yes right okay so whether they
fall vertically or downward yeah that's
true
so it might depend on the way I dropped
them so I feel ya so to make us not have
to worry about that I'll just drop them
to simultaneously pointing downwards
yeah so the fall configuration so
there's all these other variables
okay so let's do the experiment then
I'll come back to your question
okay so let's do the experiment this way
which is that I will stand on the table
and pray that I have matching socks on
which sort of eighty percent these days
it's increased and I will drop them on
the count of three one see ya are they
both about this the points about the
same level they look sort of to me but
my depth perception is actually quite
bad and yeah they're okay so is that
about equal okay one two three
simultaneous okay so there you have
choice C so now the interesting
consequence of that so what that shows
is that drag in this case is
proportional to area now it turns out
that that's not always the case so drag
very often well it's not very often in
everyday life but very easily drag can
be proportional to proportional to size
and you don't know ahead of time which
one it's going to be so it vary so it
turns out it slow speeds low Reynolds
number this is true it turns out at high
Reynolds number this is true and this is
the simplest experiment to show that so
what this shows is that drag is
proportional to area so that the with
the same velocity the extra weight is
balanced by the extra drag force exactly
four to one and what that shows now the
consequence is that
I'm going to replace the proportional
with a twiddle so it has an area in it
so I'm just going to get something with
the correct units now so it has an area
in it and now you you have left the play
with density speed and viscosity so now
let's actually construct the drag force
as a result of that so we know by the
experiment is proportional to area and
now among these so this here is the
kinematic now this is the kinematic
viscosity which is the one you may be
more familiar with divided by Rho the
density so we have to put some of these
guys in some of these guys in and some
of these guys in and make the unit's
come out as a force well one of them we
can do right away there's no there's how
many powers of mass over on this side in
a force just one right and there's none
here yet so we need to get one power of
mass on this side now among all these
guys which of them have mass in them not
this one because you divided it out not
velocity only density but in density has
one power of mass so you have to put one
density question
so this is a force good question so drag
is a force so this is just Newtons or
mass length per time squared
does it help so it's just you know it's
just Newtons in SI units or in general
mass length per time squared so a mass
times an acceleration okay so now we've
matched them units of mass and there's
but we haven't matched the units of time
yet so let's sort out the time there's
no time here there's no time there
there's T to the minus two there well
what can we do about that we have to
match we have to throw in some V and
some new and the problem is we don't
know how much so the time doesn't help
us enough turns out to make the time and
the length work the simultaneous
constraint the only way to do it is that
okay you make the same argument just get
the masses to match the lengths to match
and the times to match this is the only
way to do it so you don't have any
viscosity so actually that's the
simplest experiment I know to show that
the drag at high speed in other words
most flows are actually high speed high
Reynolds number is independent of speed
of viscosity so it's Rho AV squared and
that is a great result because it tells
you all kinds of stuff about everyday
flows in everyday life like for example
why did people reduce the speed limit on
the highway back in the 70s to conserve
gas well on the highway you're burning
gasoline to fight drag so if you reduce
the speed you reduce the drag you reduce
the amount of gasoline so in particular
if you reduce the speed by 20% we reduce
V squared by 40% which reduces the drag
by 40% so you just decrease the gas
consumption by about 40% so you can see
all these things right away just from
this simple formula which is a
immediate consequence of this experiment
okay now he turns out this how do you
get that to work this is the low
Reynolds number limit you can't deduce
it from this experiment but if you know
that this is true you can make the same
argument and figure out how the drag
force varies for low Reynolds numbers
okay so now let's just check whether
this formula here that we've deduced
works at all so the follow-up question
is the following
which is that I have one two three four
here on this side I have four small
cones they're all identical to this
small cone so I have one small cone two
small cones three small cones four small
cones so I'm gonna stack all four small
cones into a thick small cone I'm gonna
race it against one small cone so the
question is what's the ratio of these
guys's terminal speeds so it's called v4
and v1
okay so what is the ratio of their
terminal speeds 1/4 1/2 1/2 or 4 so talk
to your neighbor for just a minute I'll
take a quick vote and we'll do the
experiment okay so let's let's take a
vote and then we'll do the experiment
1/4 who votes for 1/4 ratio who votes
for 1/2 1/2 that's about 35 for 10 okay
so let's do the experiment 1 2 3 4 of
them
okay so now let me drop them like that
well it's kind of hard to tell isn't it
so that was actually not a well-designed
experiment right because you have to
actually get out a timer and decide
which one is going faster and measure
how how long they took be nice if we had
a way that was just like the other
experiment what was nice about the other
experiment is when I dropped them you
got the answer but by the fact that they
hit simultaneously so if we could make
them hit simultaneously then that would
be nice now what do I have to do to do
that well I either have to yes I have to
switch their heights four to one or two
to one so let's try four to one okay is
that sort of four to one no what do I
have to do this guy's got to go down yes
see this is where my depth perception
really fails me so I only have a
monocular vision I can see with both
eyes but I don't buy not to refuse so I
can't tell depth oh that's true pardon
oh but then you wouldn't be able to see
it so well all right so I want to do it
on the desk just so everyone can see
okay so if I lower on both like this is
that about right
four okay lower Wow okay okay one two
three go
no not very simultaneous so let's try
two two one
okay house look Alec overcompensate in
my mind into probably about two to one
is that about two to one this one yeah
every time okay
one one thousand two one thousand three
one thousand simultaneous and what's
always amazing to me is I always listen
to the class every time I do this and I
never believe them when they say it's
really two-to-one in height I was like
okay I'll trust you guys and it always
comes out simultaneous so people haven't
lied to me yet so two to one why - well
it had four times the weight same
surface area same density couldn't
change the air so you have to change the
V how much do you change the V by factor
of two because you square it and you
make up for the weight increase by a
factor of four so factor of two okay so
there you have an application of it so
now let me get to your question about
what do you do if someone tries to spoil
the experiment all right so the first
thing to do is well I should let me say
what were my reactions as soon as you
did that so my first reaction was god
damn why did he do that that was a
really nasty thing to do but then the
second reaction is so now I've developed
a habit which is a good habit to learn
of just pausing before you react to
things because you're much less likely
to cause bad interactions if you pause
so I pause to myself and I thought mmm
there's actually no point in saying how
annoyed I am right there because and
this will happen like suppose someone
tries to wreck your experiment right you
will be annoyed so it doesn't help you
to actually say how annoyed you are and
really make that person feel terrible
because then what you've done is you've
polarized the audience
against yourself besides making that
person feel bad so it's much better to
do what I did which was say okay tell
you what I'll answer your question later
but also what I tried to do was answer
it implicitly I don't know if you
noticed but what I did was when I came
to ask people I figured okay so people
sort of have an idea that it should be
see just because of somebody said well
I've seen the demonstration before
alright but what I wanted to know was
not why you think C is right but why you
think any of them could be plausible so
I I that was always part of the question
but I emphasized that part more to say
and it has a good educational purpose
which is that too you don't want to just
know you're trying to predict not just
what the quote right answer is but
you're trying to expand your repertoire
of options so you're actually making
yourself more creative by thinking what
could be plausible because it's that way
of thinking that you'll be able to use
in other problems so I tried to turn it
around a bit and push it in a direction
that it would still be a useful
discussion for people okay maybe not as
useful as if people didn't know ahead of
time that the answer was C but still a
useful one okay does that help answer
your question okay so now what we've
done we've actually gone through a whole
teaching example yes question
I didn't see that's a good point this is
a good point so I didn't and partly it's
because the right lighting in this room
is ghastly partly my eyes are not very
good but all of those reasons support
exactly what he said which is that
especially if you have a if you have a
few people in the class you can always
get away with adding one and another
thing you can do is you can always add
one for yourself you know you think well
I actually have a plausible reason for
one of these well I'm gonna vote for one
of them right and every once in a while
you vote for a correct answer but you
you know one out of five times but so
the class learns but generally you vote
sort of randomly just to give support to
the various answers so you're right it
is good the question was is it better to
not use zip ever and generally it's true
unless you're dead sure no one voted for
anything and it's hard to see in a large
class that's one of the advantages of
the clickers there's disadvantages and
advantages of clickers and we can talk
about them but you're right one way to
mitigate that just throw in an extra
vote other questions
so as I promised what we're gonna do
with this example is now because this is
actually not an aerodynamics class you
may be surprised to find out now all
right so you may have thought the
purpose was to actually learn the air
resistance formula which I if you do
learn that that's really useful and I'm
really really happy because it's a great
result which is very very very hard to
derive and pretty much any other way to
certainly can't derive it from scratch
from the navvy or Stokes equations least
no one in with current mathematical
knowledge knows how to do that so
experiment really is one of the main
ways of doing this so it's a great
result for that but what I want to use
it for is deconstructing it looking at
the way it was taught and why was all
the things were done that way so in that
discussion will come out general
principles that we'll use throughout the
semester in all of our examples of how
to do teaching which we example how to
make a lecture how to design a course
okay so as always those principles are
not very effective if I just say well
here are the principles and we're gonna
use them it's much better we actually
try them out an example and see okay
where did they show up by constructing
them so the question for the next
portion of the of this session is to
identify all of the teaching elements in
this so for example what's a teaching
element well for example there was a
vote or there was a second vote so just
deconstruct it to us find a granularity
as seems reasonable and say okay this
was done where this happened and then
why so two questions to sort of two
column table
what in why okay and there'll be a
pretty long list because there was quite
a lot of things done so find a neighbor
or two again whilst discuss the what and
why and then I'll clomp the the Y's in
two principles so any questions about
that question due to technical
difficulties the rest of lecture one is
unavailable what follows is a summary of
the material presented in the remaining
part of the lecture
you think back to me you no question
about the cones which fell faster or the
same were they the same speed the big
cone or the small cone and how that
question was asked what were all the
elements in that in the way the question
was asked what was discussed what did
you do so it was scripted very carefully
and there were reasons for the elements
of the script so we've had a chance to
think about that and let me list if many
of these scripting elements and the
reasons for them
so on the left side I'll list the
elements for example there was lots of
interaction you were talking to each
other you were asking questions
in fact you weren't just asking
questions you were voting so there was
vote twice he voted voting twice
discussing
so what are the reasons for that what
are the educational principles behind
designing a question that allows lots of
interaction voting discussing well first
of all why it gives the teacher it gives
me an idea of how the class is thinking
if for example I ask a question and in
the first vote almost everyone gets it
right I know okay everyone pretty much
understands this top this idea this
concept I can spend very little extra
time on it and move on to something that
may be more confusing or more
problematic whereas if most people get
it wrong I know okay either the book was
confusing or what I explained already
was confusing and we need to spend more
time discussing the core idea here so it
gives me instant feedback about where
the class is I don't have to wait till
the end of the term to find out on the
final exam oh no one understood that I
know right there when I have a chance to
do something about it
the voting also has another benefit so
the first benefit is it tells me it also
it makes the students form a public
commitment and that public commitment
has a strong benefit which is that the
students become much more involved in
learning what the outcome of the
discussion is because they've actually
made a public commitment to one choice
or another choice so it increases the
level of engagement similarly it creates
tension people want to know what's going
to happen so when the demonstration is
actually done you know the the final
decider is the experiment everyone is
paying very very close attention so I'll
say not just tension I'll say it creates
dramatic tension
furthermore the chance for lots of
interaction increases the amount of
interaction in the whole class in the
for example students will ask questions
much more easily if they've already had
a chance to discuss their ideas in small
groups okay so that's one set of
elements and the educational reasons for
building those in to how one asked
questions in class
another one is that I used a physical
object in an actual demonstration so
these cones and the physical object is
also cheap anyone can make those you
just cut circles out of paper cut a
quarter away and tape it together you
have a cone what are the benefits of
that
well first it's much more convincing
than if I just do a derivation from the
Navi or Stokes equations or however one
gets to the result and say okay well
therefore the drag is proportional to
the square of the speed or therefore
they all fall at the same speed whatever
their size if I just say that or even if
I'm proving with equations that's not
nearly as convincing as seeing it
actually happen and that's where in
terms of being convincing it's also
important that the demonstration be
cheap if for example to see it actually
happen requires a hundred thousand
dollars of equipment well who knows what
happens in that hundred thousand dollars
of equipment and sensors and test
devices and whatnot whereas if it's a
cheap piece of paper you can cut out for
two cents well then anyone can try it
themselves too and it's there for and
it's not so mediated by lots of sensory
devices it's much more immediate it's
much more convincing so I'll say here a
parenthesis a cheap physical object
ideally if possible
furthermore a physical object actually
connects the mathematical and physical
and engineering ideas to the physical
world in the end we want to try to
understand how the world works maybe put
it back together in ways of our choosing
so purely living in the formal world
we're living in the clouds by bringing
in physical object we actually put our
feet on the ground as well
another part of the demonstration of the
script was various things that might
have seemed extraneous for example I
mentioned that I hope my socks were
matched well when I stood on the table I
also discussed when I was standing on
the table I said ok I need the classes
help here because I don't have deaf
perception so I can't tell when I'm
dropping them when I was dropping one
cone versus four cones I can't tell when
I've got this one twice as high as this
one and so you need to tell me so I
talked about my failing in the depth
perception Department so both of these
might seem extraneous to engineering and
science but actually they have a sound
educational reason so the socks joke
well that makes a teacher
it makes the teacher see much more human
similarly for the lack of deaf
perception oh well the teacher has flaws
too they're not this perfect person who
seems to know everything and in fact
that would specifically because I didn't
have depth perception I needed the help
of the class so that again is excused to
involve the whole class so no depth
perception what makes a teacher human is
also excused for more engagement
and related to the discussing another
element of the script I want to amplify
this one up there they're discussing and
I'll put it back down here the
discussion happened first by yourself
then in a small group and then in the
whole class
together where people were suggesting
reasons so discussion so I'll say
discussions at several scales self group
and class so what's the educational
purpose of that well I mentioned one
purpose up there which is it increases
questions and that's certainly true
another one is by allowing people to
think for themself first you're giving
space for what's called the introverts
some people like lots of time to think
for themselves and only then do they
want to share with other people because
otherwise their thoughts get derailed by
what everybody else is saying some
people don't know what they're thinking
till they talk to other people let's
call them the extroverts so by allowing
space for self talk and group talk
you're teaching to the introverts and
the extroverts so you're matching to the
teaching they're learning styles of
different students in the class so
and then by scaling up slowly from self
the group to class you make it safe you
make it not a huge transition to start
to go to the next stage whereas if I
just ask the question of the class okay
whole class now you tell me what you
think about this question and I skipped
these parts only the usual suspects
would be offering me ideas here you know
the people who always raise their hand
maybe they sit in the front row whereas
by allowing people to think for
themselves then discuss in a group the
ideas that they thought with themselves
check out what they've done there if
they still think they don't understand
something you know when the group
understood it then they feel safe asking
the whole class we were actually
building a bridge for people to
participate in the large group so again
now points up there but it's so
important I'm putting it down here to
read you so call it a brave builds a
bridge to collective participation and
that participation can be people
contributing ideas or questions which
are themselves ideas
another feature of how the whole thing
was done was that I walked around a fair
amount I used this a lot of the space
for example even some of the vertical
space standing on the table moving over
here moving over there to make sure I
heard the questions from that side of
the class so so filling the lecture
space
what's the educational reason for that
well in a way it's the opposite of the
socks joke in one way it's the opposite
another way it's the same it's showing
that the teacher is human that teaching
is a human activity this is what actors
do on stage the stage the whole stage is
there for a reason and the actors will
use all of it they won't just stand in
the middle the whole time except for
rare comedy monologues or monologues but
otherwise all the pieces of the stage
are there for a reason and the actors
use it they make that space their own
space they fill the lecture room space
so as a teacher you want to do that
because that shows that this is your
space you're comfortable there and it
increases your credibility with the
students
and similar to this it brings in
students from all parts of the classroom
especially if it's a big classroom they
all feel somehow connected to what's
going on because you haven't just stood
in one corner of the room or just paid
attention to one section of the class so
in one way it's the opposite of the
socks joke because in that way the
lecture the teacher is being a bit
self-deprecating here the lecturers you
know acting very confident by filling
the space but in another way it's the
same they're both playing on human the
human part of teaching which is
inescapable and if it's neglected the
teaching falls flat and finally there
was one other point which may seem like
a mechanical point but it's so useful
that I'll put it here too and I'll write
it with big chalk at point news I wrote
everything on the board using big chalk
and why is that important well in a
small classroom room maybe 10 or 15
people it probably doesn't matter
everyone can read everything but because
it all a large classroom people can't
read the writing way in the back by
using big chalk you increase the
signal-to-noise ratio
now that may not seem so important when
you first think about it the reason
being is that you already know what
you're writing so even if you see really
thin lines something that's not very
clearly written you still know what it
should say and you just read it
correctly but the students on the other
hand they don't have the knowledge that
you have so they can't error correct any
fill in the missing gaps in the lines
they need as much signal as possible to
really copy down anything correctly to
make sure that they're not adding noise
onto the signal that you're trying to
get across so in some ways a small point
but in other ways an important point
because if you don't do it you'll throw
away most of your other benefits because
the students will actually be
incorporating wrong information just
errors just by mistake without even
realizing and the big chalk can actually
minimize that so just a mechanical point
I always keep pieces of big chalk in my
backpack
and wherever I happen to be teaching I
can always pull them out and use them
because you will find many classrooms
only have standard chalk provided and
the big chalk is something you have to
do yourself so just carry a few pieces
with you as you need okay so those are
some of the many scripting elements in
this example and you'll see a similar
example in a subsequent lecture in the
lecture on teaching interactively which
is lecture 6 and you'll see some of
these points come up again and some of
these reasons discussed again in a
different example so you'll have two
different engineering examples but done
in a similar way you can see the
scripting elements and how they're
different and how they're the same in
both examples and see which ones you can
use your own teaching so now from these
scripting elements we've extracted
teaching principles so credibility
signal-to-noise ratio just remember
those
and then here's a bunch more yeah I want
to summarize them I want to extract the
the main highlights from that so that
you can come away with a clean picture
of what to watch for throughout the
semester so the main themes of all of
these are I would say they fall into
three categories let me list them and
they'll break them into three categories
there's ways to promote questions and
discussion
there's using stories and humor and
demos and related to that things you can
see visual examples
and another pair of environments of
credibility filling the lecture space
and what I haven't directly said yep as
such but we'll call it a safe
environment for learning creating a safe
environment for learning
that's what discussion at several scales
enables you created a safe environment
for people to think for themselves which
then makes it safe for them to think in
a group and discuss in group which then
makes it safe for them to think in a
whole class and so that makes it safe a
safe bridge or two bridges towards
collective participation so you made a
safe learning and questioning
environment without this environment
that would happen I put these in three
columns because I think they fall into
sort of three pieces of the brain
questions and discussion sort of
left-brain stories humor demos and
visual that's yeah right brain and
credibility in a safe environment I'll
call that the emotional brain the
amygdala maybe you could put humor over
there as well but the reason I put for
example stories with the right brain is
it's a different kind of learning than
we think of even when we think of left
brain learning where you're for example
learning an analytical method or a
sequence of steps or a recipe the
learning that happens from stories for
example about this the depth perception
is a different kind it's kind of
implicit in a way more perceptive and
holistic so I put it in the right brain
category so these are sort of main
themes in creating your own classroom
teaching environment
and structuring how you're gonna teach
and sure there's also thought all the
questions of content but the reason I'm
focusing on all of these is that the
questions of content those have been
done so many so many times you can find
all the content in a gazillion different
textbooks but the question is how do you
integrate all that content into
something that makes for a good student
learning and to do that need to take
account of all this all of these
features all these aspects of the brain
because humans are not computers and
they can't just learn by being
programmed so from all these themes
extract one giant theme which is that
teaching is not necessarily equal to
learning just standing up there and
teaching stuff is no guarantee that
students will learn it you need to pay
attention to all these features of the
human interaction to make sure that
learning actually happens so that's if
anything the main theme or phrase
another way is that meaning and
knowledge must be constructed by the
learner
and all these ideas up here the
scripting elements these principles here
are ways to help that construction
happen just telling them doesn't do it
you have to enable facilitate that
construction so what we're gonna do for
the rest of the semester is we're gonna
see these principles these principles
these boiled down themes these this idea
this large idea the big idea of the
entire course exemplified in several
topics and areas that are central to
teaching science and engineering and
mathematics at the college level and so
the outline for the rest of the semester
is as follows today today was lecture 1
and that was general principles of
teaching
the next one will be on how to teach
equations equations are central in all
science and mathematics and engineering
teachings so how do you teach equations
in other words some of the central
content taking account of all these
ideas can you tell stories when you
teach equations how can you do that well
we'll see this third lecture the third
topic is taking account of students
misconceptions and thereby avoiding rote
learning so you can see already where
some of the ideas that we've been
talking about here are going to help
here
for example having lots of interaction
and voting you find out where the
students are you'll find out if they
have funny ways of thinking about stuff
maybe even predictable ways but ways
that don't help them actually solve
problems in the real world well how do
you take account of that there's one way
right there already then designing
homework and exam problems
and the fifth one is course design how
do you structure a whole course
sixth one is teaching interactively as
an example you've already seen one
example which is this kind of question
well what are the general principles
behind such questions can you make
longer versions shorter ones are there
short ways of building and interaction
and questions into learning then what do
you actually do when you come into the
classroom lecture planning and
performing how do you plan one lecture
so this is the overall structure of the
whole course how do you plan and perform
one lecture
topic 8 is teaching with blackboards and
slides so what are the advantages of
generally speaking of blackboards but
when our situation what are situations
where slides are actually a really
helpful way to teach slides meaning well
it could be old-style photographic
slides but or pre-prepared PDF files
that are projected on the screen with an
LCD projector it's generally how it's
done now and then how do you plan
blackboard work how do you construct
slides so that they're effective in
creating learning
ix is sort of a result of all of these
well if you're going to apply all these
principles you'll find yourself wanting
to change a lot about how the course is
done or how it was done previously well
what are the barriers to that in
particular what are the political
barriers to educational change
so that by being aware of the barriers
you're more able to go around them
surmount them take account of them plan
for doing it bit by bit by bit but
eventually hopefully designing courses
in ways that you think are good for
promoting learning and then the 10th
topic will be a summary of everything
using the examples we've done the whole
semester and a chance for well you'd ask
questions about the whole course okay so
that's the themes of this entire
semester of teaching college-level
science and engineering one topic at a
time see everyone next week answers from
lecture two two questions generated in
lecture one what I'm going to do is
answer your questions from last time the
feedback sheets and I'll pass out a new
set of feedback sheets in a moment so I
should say that the questions were has
always excellent and I learned a lot by
thinking about them and I hope that you
learned a lot by as you hear the results
of everyone else's questions together
and that they reflect concerns that
maybe all of you had it two different
levels and the question that you may
have put down may not have been all of
your concerns but collectively hopefully
it captures most of them so I'll
categorize the first section of
questions as in reality you know I'm
gonna put actually all I typed in all
the questions I'm gonna put them all on
the course website so you can see the
questions the answers will be here but
you'll see the questions so in reality
so in reality one question of that along
that line is what about grading how do
you actually implement your grading
policy as an assistant professor in a
traditional department so my grading
policy you know is generally that
especially in the past
fail course that the grading be very
minimal and in general I think that's a
good policy for braining overall and we
can talk throughout the semester about
why and the research behind that but how
would you do that if you're starting out
new and the general rule is there's no
right answer for example one solution is
it's not quite the answer to the
question is to take a position at a
place where you're the department head
so actually I was offered a position a
teaching position like that
after I finished graduate school and I
thought long and hard about it so I
would have been the head of the physics
and math department now that was the
good side the bad side would was that I
was the only member of the both
departments and so on the one hand I was
a department head but also I was the
only one doing all the teaching and I
would have only me to boss around but in
that situation you do have a huge amount
of freedom and I could have done pretty
much whatever I wanted all right now I
decided not to take that position
because I really wasn't sure exactly
what I wanted to do in terms of
improving teaching and I thought well I
really need some more experience than I
decided to do to do a postdoc but that
is one solution to that problem
it's not a very generalizable solution
it doesn't there not many positions like
that another solution is to what I call
the caught thief Clark Kent solution so
you you go around as a traditional
faculty member you know in the Clark
Kent outfit and then as soon as you get
tenure boom off comes the suit and if it
realizes that oh actually we hired
someone else completely who actually has
all these interesting ideas about
teaching so that is generally legally
protected to some extent and you won't
easily be fired
although a colleague of mine in Canada
is the university's threat is trying to
fire him for giving all A's in a course
yeah so this does speak to this question
and it shows it is a tricky issue so he
believes and I agree with him that
grades generally just produce obedient
people that one of their main functions
to produce obedient people and median
students rather than students who love
learning and want the question all right
so he wanted to teach one of his courses
he's a tenured professor of physics he
wanted to teach one of his courses
pass/fail and the university said no by
university regulations that course is
graded only has to be taught with grades
so he said ok fine on the first day of
class he just told everyone they were
gonna get an A+
and according to the TA at least the so
this was then reported in Canada's Globe
and Mail they're sort of New York Times
then one of the teaching assistants in
the course said yeah there were a few
students who took advantage of that fact
but most actually did more work and work
you know were very interested in the
material because of it
but so I would say basically the thing
was a success and that's generally what
I find that the less emphasis you put on
grades especially at a place like MIT
the students natural interest in the
material comes out and they're more and
more willing to work and learn and
that's produces long lasting learning
because they're doing it for their own
reasons not because you stood over them
with a grade and beat them over the head
so I that was good the bad part is the
university basically said well you're
defying us and you're you know going
against the purpose of the university
not really clear what the purpose of the
university is except maybe to produce
obedient people so they said we're gonna
institute proceedings for your dismissal
to strip you of your tenure and fire you
which is a big step right for a tenured
professor and meanwhile they banned it
from campus so he's now not allowed on
his own university campus so then he
came to campus for a film screening
because he runs a film series on the
campus so he came for that and the
university police arrested so he was
arrested for going to his own University
so then it got into the national press
in Canada which doesn't make the
university look so good but that's all
by way of saying that grading is a very
touchy issue with the universities and
it's really not clear
to do about it because it's so embedded
in the system so I can't really offer
you any solutions to that question
except to say that it's a very tricky
negotiation and you want to plan your
activities carefully you know if you're
gonna use a lighter grading system you
know don't do it all at once you know
get people around you to accept it
slowly-slowly get students on your side
slowly you know do things slowly don't
make any sudden moves to get yourself
fired work with other people of like
minds work together collectively so it's
not a long term you know instant
solution but any kind of social problem
and I think grading is a social problem
it doesn't have any instant solutions so
I want to answer that one first to
basically tell you that I don't have all
the answers to all the questions and I
want to give you honest answers as far
as I know those okay next question about
reality you've obviously done this many
times before as someone who needs to
figure out a logical order for the
material in addition to balancing
preparation time and research how do we
juggle all this in addition to simply
focusing on style so I want to dispel
one misconception was that last time I
wasn't saying that you can substitute
style for preparation and really knowing
the material it's really that I wanted
to up the importance that people give to
what people would call style by saying
that the way you present how you present
is as important as what you present in
fact it is to some extent what you
present if for example you're very
interested in the material and you
presented in that way well the students
are very naturally going to become
interested in the material as a test of
this you can actually do little home
experiments in this principle so just go
around to somebody you can do these
little like candid camera experiments
you just go up to them and smile just
like this and then watch what they do
right and a whole bunch of people
actually just smiled back at me for no
reason at all just because I smiled now
not no reason at all
is because we're social creatures we're
programmed from millions of years of
evolution to pick up other people's
emotions and ways
of being so if you're enthusiastic about
the material if you're interested in it
you present it like it's important well
that actually gets transmitted very
effectively and picked up at the other
end very effectively so actually that is
part of the content so I wouldn't say
style is separate from the content how
you present how you think about the
material is crucially important part of
the material because that's what
students are going to be taking away and
that's going to be affecting how they
think about the material so it's not
just focusing on style I would that sort
of gives it too little importance they
said yeah how do you think about all
those issues as well as surviving your
research grant and again they're I would
say the way to do it is to start slow
right when you're an assistant professor
you need to focus on your research to
get tenure so focus on your research and
just try small teaching experiments bit
by bit right maybe in your first year
just try putting in one kind of small
conceptual question per lecture or per
week right and if that goes okay maybe
try longer ones try more more the next
semester or the next year so just try
small things and as they work grow them
okay so that's one way so you don't have
to sacrifice your research and hose
yourself so preparation time as well you
know so try to borrow notes from
colleagues try to get as much from other
people as you can share you know talent
invents genius steals so steal all the
good stuff around you so another one is
how does this work in the real world
which is basically the same thing so
what I'm trying to do in this class is
show you general principles that you can
use always to guide yourself and as far
if you want to go in your teaching so
now how far you go in your particular
situation depends on your situation and
how much importance you put on doing new
teaching methods new experiments right
then all right but I'm not saying you
have to start everything tomorrow like
the first day or a TA
all of a sudden throughout all the
regular stuff and do everything like I'm
demonstrating now I'm showing you this
as examples to illustrate principles for
directions you could go and for threads
you can pick up
you see best ok syllabus and logistics
for this class any exams or problem sets
yeah there's problem sets which you've
seen one already no exams done and so
how are you being evaluated basically
again very light touch basically just
make a reasonable effort on the problem
sets and you'll be fine I'm hoping
basically that the material is
interesting enough that you don't need a
stick meeting you saying oh you must do
this you must do that you must do this
it's not a required course people are
taking it really because they're
interested so I'm not gonna try to ruin
that with a whole bunch of grading
sticks ok does it matter which subject
number we're assigned for no and I don't
even remember what the subject numbers
are I know 5 9 5 and there's a whole
bunch of them so I just write etc no
doesn't matter as far as I know could we
have a break after one hour yeah I think
that's a good idea so I'll give everyone
like a two or three minute break at the
hour just so you can stand and get your
blood flowing again biology examples
could we have biology examples a fair
point so actually today our first
example of equations is a biology
example amazingly okay so now
interactive teaching how do you teach a
class interactively if you have a lot of
material to get through this is a very
interesting question it comes up quite
often and the answer is that you don't
get through it in the lecture so the
lecture is a terrible place to get
through lots of material in fact even
the word get through cover those all
have the wrong sense to them and so
Victor Weisskopf you know MIT physics
professor for many years he said and I
think it's the great saying instead of
covering a lot of material I prefer to
uncover a few key ideas so uncover is
the right verb not cover has the sense
of smother you can't see it anymore and
that is what happens when you cover too
much material you want to uncover a few
ideas and let them blue so lecture
lecture is something that's paced at
human scale right you talk at maybe 150
the words a minute people can't write
that fast picking right maybe 15 words a
minute my reading is much faster reading
people can read 300 maybe 400 words a
minute you can so if you have lots of
material to get through don't fall into
the trap of putting it all on the
blackboard or on the overhead slides and
we'll talk about that in the session on
making good slides and using the
blackboard you want key ideas to be
there and you can leave a lots of the
details for reading okay so that's one
approach
one answer the other answer is that
sometimes actually I think one of the
fundamental problems with so much
teaching is that we try to cover too
much material and one of the goals
should be for good teaching is to reduce
how much material one covers and there's
a simple estimation argument to show why
that's important the estimation argument
is that basically suppose you cover 100%
of the material but because it's so much
material students remember only 10% and
really learn only 10% which i think is
actually a reasonable estimate and
they're just so overloaded they have no
time to make connections and it just
flutters away so 10% is all a routine
well you could cover say half the
material and let's say that they still
don't remember everything even though
you've done half maybe they remember
half of that because they have time to
struggle with it make connections so now
they're at half of half which is 25
percent retention instead of 10% so
that's a plausible model not claiming
those figures are actually based on
exact research or anything but just a
plausible model for how reducing the
amount of stuff you cover can actually
increase learning so try to reduce
material when possible they're almost
always there's too much material ok so
again how do you paste lectures if you
do too many demos then you have less
material advanced students might get
bored actually I find advanced students
are actually quite interested in demos
and questions like this that we used
last time they want to really understand
what's going on and it's those kind of
questions that help them covering lots
of material again they can read it in a
book much faster than you can write it
on the board so put it there
can these principles be applied to upper
level graduate classes for sure you can
apply them all the way from kindergarten
to graduate school because they're
really based on how people think and
they're based on common ways that people
perceive the world and reason that
doesn't change I mean life does change
when you become a graduate student but
your whole way of looking at the world
doesn't change that much okay so how do
you deal with classes where someone
dominates a discussion or the class does
not like to participate sort of two ends
of the same coin so what I like to do is
if someone keeps trying to say stuff I
just say oh well actually I want
everybody to participate could I hear
from someone I haven't heard from and
just with a light touch you know have to
make a big confrontation in class about
it if people don't like to participate
for example suppose you ask them to
discuss with each other and they don't
so here's a trick I learned actually
from one of the teaching seminars when I
was in England which is that you just
turn your back and why do you do that
well your back is not as interesting as
your front so you know students are
actually taught with say 12 years of
teaching to watch the teacher watch the
teacher right so one of the reluctance
is to talk to each other's they're
watching the teacher figure out what the
teachers saying and doing right like
done clever Huntz was watching his
trainer you know how do I do more clips
on my foot is it 42 six times seven 40
so students are actually taught
basically after 12 years of conditioning
or do that very automatically so you
just have to break that conditioning a
bit if you just turn around there's
nothing really that interesting to look
at unless you're maybe I don't know some
fashion model or a GQ model which I'm
not claiming to be so then the students
will just naturally be more likely to
talk to each other so you create the
conditions for that do you know the one
is and I often use this trick because
it's actually not a trick is sometimes
I'm thirsty I just walk out of the room
and go get a drink of water all right so
if it's the interesting enough question
the students will be talking to each
other about it and there's definitely
not you around there watching them and
wearing them with them to focus on so
that's one very useful trick generally
though
overall point is if the class doesn't
want to participate you just make it
more and more safe to participate you
make sure you never criticize people if
they say something that wasn't right you
make sure you value the wrong answers
and you explain why so all the things I
talked about last time about safety
means you just have to do them double if
people aren't participating okay how do
you cope with a variety of confidence
levels among students also interesting
so there I find actually that most
students aren't very confident they have
different levels of they're all
generally much lower than you think so
they do have some different levels but
it's generally low overall lower than
you think so I spend more of my effort
making sure everyone feels comfortable
but again if some students are much more
confident than others I try to mix up
the level of questions that I ask I ask
some questions that I know most people
are not going to be able to answer and
some questions I know most people will
answer just so everyone has something
you can on the problem sets as well
warmup problems regular problems really
hard problems like in donald knuth
textbooks the the fifth set of kind of
problem at the end of the chapters is
unsolved research problems and you never
know someone might actually solve one of
them so you can keep put something for
everyone in there okay what about the
left brain surely humor and demos can't
take you all the way yeah and that's
true and so my answer to what about the
left brain is that the left brain is
well basically most teaching is focused
on for the last for most people's
experience for the last fifteen or
sixteen years so I'm not saying forget
about the left brain I'm saying that you
basically already know how to do the
left brain side of teaching right you
have mahtim so many models of that it is
pretty much what we think of it's
teaching you go up to the blackboard and
you write down series of symbols one
after another write down a series of
equations so you already have models for
that not and we'll talk about how to
improve those but I'm not so worried
about that part what I'm worried about
is the neglected part so this you could
think of as
the balance and hoe and then you'll be
able to find ways of integrating the
left brain and will do left brain things
equations but how do you integrate that
with all the quote right brain the humor
and the demos okay how do you project
confidence fake it till you make it yeah
that's basically right one way to
project so one way is to actually make
sure your voice is clear so to do that
the my piano teacher in graduate school
I she was a voice teacher as well she
gave me a really useful exercise which
is you I do this for like 30 seconds
before I come to lecture so the exercise
is you first you just close your lips
and you you hum yeah I said well I'll do
this together so you hum until you can
feel it vibrating in your nose because
that's step one so let's all do that
together
and if you have hay fever you can tell
if you're doing it right in the spring
because you'll dislodge pollen grains
and you'll probably sneak that's what I
find in the spring when I do that I
actually start sneezing just my theory
is that I'm dislodging pollen grains now
and then I'm sneezing as a result of
them so mm-hmm
so now you've got resonance up here and
now what you want to do is with the same
mmm so now do it in the back of your
teeth with your mouth closed so you feel
it behind your teeth
so we'll do step 1 and then step 2 mmm
and then the teeth mmm
and should feel it in your lips
vibrating kind of tickling okay so
that's step two step three is to then
make the vowel sound that is most likely
to make your mouth resonate and be
really wide open that's e so we'll go
and then mm and then e okay so nose
okay that's step three and then it's the
final step is you just had some words
you modulate it with words all right so
I'll give you a demonstration then we'll
do all all of it together how are you
okay so now that sounds a bit strange
but you find after you do that your
voice is much more resonant actually I
can hear it right now I might to my own
ears my voice sounds much more resonant
and clear so let's do that
me how are you
hmm so you'll find actually what you've
done is you've shifted your voice from
here where it just makes your throat
tight to the front and just by doing
that you'll project and by projecting
you actually sound more confident and
you'll feel more confident so that's one
way but another way you know to be
confident of your material and another
way is as you said in the question just
fake it till you make it okay now there
was a few more questions I'll answer
some on the website and but I wanted to
answer one more how long did it take you
to become such a good teacher
so um I had people think I'm a good
teacher or at least one person think so
but there's a general answer to that
question which is actually going to be
one of the topics today which is how do
you become an expert in anything okay
and the example the first example I'm
going to show you it's biology equations
I'm gonna use that and then after that
I'm going to talk about expertise in
general not just in teaching and where
that comes from and I'll show you the
results of some studies
so hopefully that and then I'll come
back to that question there I'll
hopefully answer it then okay all right
so those are say I would say two-thirds
of the questions the ones I haven't
answered I'll try to answer online and
I'll pass out these in just a moment but
right now what we're going to do is
we're going to do the first example of
equations which is from biology that
before I do that any questions that have
occurred to you meanwhile did I create
any new questions yes
I think it's automatic I don't think
there's any way not to register as PDF
yeah so the question was if this is
pass/fail do you have to specifically
register that I don't think so I think
it's automatic so yeah basically don't
worry about your grades
everyone's gonna pee